[Music]
what are some of the misconceptions that
you've heard about yourself I think the
one that I guess hurts the most is that
people think I'm a mean girl because
that's just not the case Kendall Jenner
wants you to know those rumors she's not
nice are not true it's not always easy
on the Kardashians the model opens up
about having anxiety in public settings
during a work trip to Vegas I know I'm
here for work and there's a part of me
that's enjoying myself and there's a
part of me that's just really anxious
because I don't always love big crowds
for probably some obvious reasons and
then also just I don't know I feel like
anything I do anything gets hate like I
could be walking down the street doing
absolutely nothing and somebody always
has something bad to say
and I think the narrative has gotten so
out of hand about me and my family that
there's just no changing it anymore
growing up in the spotlight Kendall and
her sister Kylie know a thing or two
about negative narratives it is
extremely difficult and you're growing
and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but there's so many
blessings that come along with it too so
we're grateful for it not much to
complain about and just recently Kenny
told Bogue it's something she struggled
with since she was a kid I'd say like
eight nine ten like around that time and
I remember having shortness of breath
and going to my mom and telling her that
in hindsight now I know that that was
obviously anxiety I mean there is going
to be those people that say like oh okay
what does she have to worry about what
does she have to be anxious about and
because of all that the Kardashian Stars
shutting down the biggest misconception
of them all the rumor she's a mean girl
that's just not the case it can be
upsetting when someone is questioning
your character and if only like people
knew me I think both Kylie and I kind of
knew what we wanted to keep off the show
or what we wanted to keep to ourselves
and yeah I think that it's kind of as
simple as that sure she's an
international model and it's done
reality TV most of her life but Kendall
she just wants to live a simple life I
could crave the complete opposite I want
to be
on a farm in Wyoming with a ton of
animals that's where I want to be
getting wasted getting wasted like the
drunk part is cool
and as far as dealing with her mental
health struggles Kendall's proud of how
far she's come I consider it like a like
a beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
and I I like that I am really aware of
my body and like my mind I know it can
sometimes get the best of me but I think
that I really I like that I'm in tune
and I like that I like you know want to
know everything
[Music]
foreign
[Music]